سباق الرئاسه التركيه التي انطلق يوم
الرابع عشر من مايو لم تكن نتائجه ضيقه او
متقاربه بل تفوق اردوغان على كليتش دور
اوغلو باكثر من مليونين ونصف المليون صوت
هذا التفوق لم يمكن اردوغان بالطبع من
الوصول الى النسبه الحاسمه للفوز والمقدره
بخمسين زائد واحد فصل بين اردوغان وبين
هذه النسبه فصل بينهما اقل من نصف نقطه
مئويه ولكن الكثير قد يتغير اذا
ذهبت اصوات سنان
المقدره باكثر من مليونين و800 الف صوت
لاي من المرشحين حتى اننا قد نرى محافظه
قد صوتت الى كمالك لتجدار اوغلو تذهب الى
اردوغان في الاعاده والعكس ايضا قابل
للتحقيق من ابرز هذه المحافظات نذكر في
الجنوب
حيث تفوق هناك لتشدار اوغلو ب 481 صوتا
فقط بمعنى انها من المرجح ان تنقلب لصالح
اردوغان اذا قرر اكثر من 30 الف شخص فقط
اذا صوتوا لسنان اوغان هناك ان يصوتوا
للرئيس الوضع ايضا قد يحدث في العاصمه
انقره طبعا انقره فاز كليتش دور اوغلو
فيها باكثر من 50 الف صوت ولكن يوجد نحو
ربع مليون صوت في حوزه سنان اوغان هناك
ايضا محافظه اردوغان التاريخيه اسطنبول
التي صوتت
قد تنقلب في جوله الاعاده لنفس الاسباب
اذا بشكل عام ابرز المحافظات التي قد
تنقلب اصواتها لصالح اردوغان هي الاتيه
هاتاي
بديليس دنزيلي
وايضا
وانقر واسطنبول كما ذكرنا اما المحافظات
التي قد يخسرها اردوغان اذا قرر سنان
اوغان ان يقف ضده فهي ارتوين او ارتفين
واوساك وايضا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات